talk to me about the athletic governing  bodies if you had a message that you  could send to them directly what would  that be  um well I think the piece I want to hit  on is the lack of accountability like I  mentioned earlier there is no one  willing to  face this issue head on  um directly and say exactly how they  feel it's been a lot of beating around  the bush it's been turning to other  organizations  um and since you know doing this  especially the NCAA  um  they nominated well you Penn nominated  Thomas for NCAA woman of the year which  was then approved by the NCAA which is  the highest honor in all of college  sports and to nominate someone who has  spent five percent of their life as a  female is wrong we're encouraging that  we're celebrating that then sobole is  praising this